welcome to date of is deaf talk I'm your
host Venus Kazi developer advocate for
data studio in this episode for data vis
deaf talk you'll learn how attenti
kitchen flow works for community
collectors and how you can authorize
your users to use external services
let's get started when a user tries to
use a connector for the first time data
studio triggers the connector
authorization flow connector
authorization is a two-step process
first the Google auth to flow is
triggered to allow data studio to
execute the connector this flow includes
all the necessary scopes required by the
connector we talked about the board
scopes in our episode about manifests in
the first step the user will review the
scopes and complete the authorization
process in the second step data studio
triggers additional outflow if the
connector needs to reach any external
service this second step is initiated by
the estudio by making the get off type
call to the connector at this point
there are several use cases when you
will not need any additional credentials
from the user the first use case is if
you're not connecting to any external
service for example if you're connecting
to the Google fit API the auth scope
will be a part of the Google auth to
flow and no further authorization is
required the second use case is if
you're connecting to an external service
that does not require the user to
authenticate for example if you're
fetching data from the NPM download
count public API it does not require any
kind of authentication and the last use
case is if you're accessing external
services using a private secret like a
service ii credential or a token for
example the stack overflow API requires
an API key you can generate your own API
key throw it in your strip properties
and use the store API key every API call
you make in these use cases you will
return the off type none for the get off
type response data studio will then
proceed with the collector configuration
however if you require users credentials
to authenticate to external services you
should return the auth type required by
your specific external service your
options for authentication include API
key user name and password user name in
token and OAuth 2 for a complete list of
authentication types
check out the reference link for the get
hot type in the description below if the
service you're connecting to requires
the user to provide their credentials
via an auth to process you should use
the OAuth 2 for app scripts library this
will make the implementation a lot
easier the library will also be useful
if you're using service accounts with an
auth
to base service in this type of
authentication data studio will open a
new window and redirect the user to the
service providers login screen once the
user logs in and provides the necessary
permissions to the connector the user
will be able to resume the connector
configuration in data studio if you're
using the OAuth 2 for Apps Script
library in your connector code you'll be
able to access the user token through
the library an advanced tip if your
connector is connecting to your own
service you have the flexibility to set
up any kind of custom authentication and
authorization flow at your end
using the OAuth 2 method if your
connector requires a different
authentication than plus two like API
key or username password data studio
will render the required interface so
the user can provide the credentials in
data studio you should use the app strip
property service and store these
credentials in the user property store
and fetch them when required you'll need
to write a few additional functions in
your code if you're using any odd type
other than none
these functions will allow data studio
to verify the credentials and reset them
when required details above these
functions how to implement them along
with code examples are available in the
authentication guide linked in the
description below to learn more check
out the links in the description below
and don't forget to subscribe to the GCP
channel for more great content on data
studio thanks for watching and until
next time keep building awesome
dashboards
you
[Applause]